I think we're studying a little bit of a
precedence for others who would want to
move here and live this type of
lifestyle it really should be the
township here
Kelly Vander clay hunter has spent the
last three years building her dream of a
small family farm in Matawan Michigan in
the last three months fighting the local
Township government to keep it our
animals are definitely part of our
family although most of them have a
purpose
the chickens obviously take care of the
bugs the cats take care of the mice the
donkeys take care of the Coyotes that
come after the chickens the kids love
them they have names we're very very
conscious of making sure that they're
happy this is a happy farm
we pretty much sunk every penny that we
owns into it so when I got that letter
that stated I was not in compliance it
like knocked the wind out of my sails
the letter requires the hunters to give
up more than half of their animals
because of zoning complications
complications that arose after the
family spent countless hours and poured
nearly $50,000 into renovating the farm
when we first purchased the home it was
in a state of disrepair there was so
much overgrowth around the bar and you
couldn't really even see the backside of
it
within days of purchasing we started
clearing the property they built a home
for their horse two donkeys chickens
ducks and turkeys the hunters had
checked before purchasing the home to
ensure that farm animals were indeed
allowed we learned that it's owned r1
which is rural residential and it does
say specifically that lifestyle
operations small hobby farms that type
of thing are allowed we called the
township to ask them to come out and
just check things out make sure things
were okay which they did and they said
we weren't doing anything wrong that's
why this revision came as such a shock
animals located on property
the Zoning Administrator determined that
the hunters were not in compliance with
the township zoning ordinance it sounds
a little bit like they decided to
reinterpret the way the ordinance was
being read and so that put us out of
compliance the local government can
change the zoning of any parcel of land
like that the township says that the
firm's nearly five acres isn't enough
land for the animals but vice president
of Reason Foundation Adrienne Moore says
that's completely arbitrary
there's no formulas for figuring out how
much land you need for which kind of
animals the owners of animals should be
able to treat their animals as they
please
house their animals as they please
unless there's some obvious cruelty or
harm going on it's very frustrating to
know that they don't seem to understand
what we're trying to do I grew up in a
rural community where I worked on farms
pretty much my whole life and I
understand the importance of learning
hard work through hands-on experience it
was very important to me and to my
husband that we find a way to introduce
our children to that kind of work ethic
but all this hard work didn't matter
once an unhappy neighbor complained to
the township and got politicians
involved
this is neighbors complaining about
neighbors not in the courts which is
where those kind of disputes are
supposed to go under our system but
instead they took it to the political
court which unfortunately has become
more and more popular in this country
and so it's being played out basically
on crony politics rather than any kind
of real objective standards the fact
that the neighbors are using the
political process rather than the court
systems already says they've got a
somewhat suspicious suspicious complaint
the Matawan community largely agrees
that the complaints are unfounded and
they've packed the townhall on two
occasions now to speak out why do these
people move here when they don't want to
be in a rural area I think the bar is
the members of the Township board
Planning Commission and Zoning Board of
Appeals work out a solution that would
allow them to continue with their happy
it's one of the wonderpana because it's
a beautiful property I wish my apartment
a peg the support that we've received
from all of us has been completely
overwhelming I've never experienced
anything like it this is an example of a
Township that is pushing it farther than
the community seems to be willing to go
along with you you just can't believe
how many things you cannot do on your
own property unless the government lets
you we feel like we're under a
microscope we feel like everything we do
on our own property we have to get
permission from the township now forget
about your property rights they almost
don't exist in the early part of
America's history we relied on
constitutional constraints and
governments just didn't go and interfere
in what was clearly not the public's
business but was private business but
that has eroded dramatically in the last
hundred years in America and despite the
uphill battle ahead
the hunters plan to keep fighting the
township for their farm where we go from
here we have no idea I can't give up
this is why we are here this is our
whole purpose for being in this place I
would like to not move because of us
because it really would be very
expensive heartbreaking for us to move
at this point when we love this place so
much
you